مستخرجه من هذا الفطر فطر عيش الغراب الذي
يوصف بالسحري عقاقير مخدره ستصبح متاحه
للمرضى النفسيين في استراليا بعد اقرار
اداره السلع العلاجيه استخدام ماده
الموجوده في هذا الفطر لعلاج المرضى
المصابين باضطراب ما بعد الصدمه والاكتئاب
الحاد القرار يدخل حيز التنفيذ ابتداء من
يوليو المقبل وبذلك تكون استراليا اول
دوله بالعالم تشرع استخدام تلك العقاقير
الا ان هذا الاستخدام سيكون مشروطا بان
تكون حاله المريض مستعصيه ولم تتحسن
بالعلاج النفسي ومضادات الاكتئاب المعروفه
مثل عقار اكستاسي كذلك يجب ان يكون المريض
مراقبا بغرف علاجيه خاصه يقضي فيها مده
تقارب العشر ساعات بعد اخذه للدواء قبل ان
يسمع له بالعوده لمنزله وذلك لضمان زوال
اي اثار كالهلوسه تقديرات طبيه اشارت الى
ان المريض قد يحتاج 45 ساعه من الجلسات
العلاجيه وقد تبلغ تكلفتها بين 15 و30 الف
دولار